hey everyone this is Kim from the chess
website.com and today we're continuing
our coverage the 2017 at champions
showdown we're gonna be looking at day
three today between Topalov and Nakamura
if you're not familiar with the
champions showdown you are matched up
head-to-head against one individual we
have four matchups eight players in
total and you play that person for 30
games over a four-day spam they range
from rapid games the first day they
played four games of 30 minutes each
then next day day two they played six
games and they had 20 minutes and then
day three we're gonna be playing eight
games and they only get ten minutes so
this is getting into the Blitz portion
Topol I've had a rough couple days
against Nakamura he's down three games
to Nakamura and so we get into it
White's gonna be played by Topalov in
this game and blacks gonna be played by
nakamura starts out with pawn to e4 and
then pawn c5 not f3 pawn d6 and this is
the Sicilian defense and specifically
when we talk about the Sicilian offense
it really comes down to what black does
and he plays pawn to a6 this is the NIE
Dorf defense if you go back to day two
we looked at the first game that topalov
played coming into day two and it was
this it was the pawn to e4 met by the
Sicilian defense from Nakamura and he
saw the knight Dorf and he played a very
specific movie played pawn to f3 which
is what he does now pawn to e6 Bishop e3
pawn h5 from Nakamura but today it plays
Queen to d2 in the game yesterday that
he lost coming out he played this in
game 1 he played Bishop to c3 the
problem was in that game he eventually
brought his Bishop back to b3 Nakamura
put a lot of pressure on his opponent he
eventually traded his Knight for this
Bishop on b3 so blob recapture with this
pawn here from the sea to square and it
just kind of unraveled from there to
Apple I've had a really high
time coming back from that so decided
not only for today but even in the later
games cuz every time he played white
yesterday in day 2 he played this same
opening but he played a little bit
differently and this is the first time
he's going for a Queen to d2 so more
than likely he was thinking about it
after his games yesterday talking with
his team as well and decided that Queen
to d2 is the better variation for the
style that he wants to be playing Bishop
to e7 from Nakamura Bishop e2 Bishop d7
castle on at the queenside night here c6
just simple development getting involved
into the middle of the board pawn to g3
really seeing this in all of the
variations that took lavas playing pawn
be 5 and then pawn a3 and this specific
setup is what I think Toa blob was
getting after with his team for the most
part the rest of the board state on both
sides is exactly the other games that he
had the difference is where this light
square bishop is and then where this
pawn is you don't want to be playing
your pawn up here to a3 if your bishops
here and your opponent already has their
knight on a 5 and they can exchange then
you have two pawns here on B 3 and a 3
it's just really really difficult for
white to continue here so Topalov I
think as they were studying says this is
where I want to get to so he continues
pawn here to a3 rook the c8 always want
to bring these rooks to semi open files
to control that so now black says the F
I'm gonna Castle it's gonna be to the
King side of the board King bee one
night a5 it's not doing as much as it
was before attacking the bishop on b3
Soto pops fine with this pawn to h3 just
solidifying at this square here control
of the g4 square pawn g6 a lot of fun
the pawns hand on the King side for
black pawn g4 says let's go ahead and
break up this King side you know I've
already castle on the Queen side so I'm
gonna start throwing everything I can at
the King side of the board pawn to e5
and then Knight back here to b3 says
don't mind exchanging with my Knights
here this is gonna be completely fine
decided not to do that right away Bishop
to e6 it's gonna be extremely bad if
there's not an exchange happening fast
you know white could take here on a5 if
he wants he could bring his knight back
here to see one can't really just stay
here because only one defender with the
pawn and both the knight and the bishop
are attacking it c1 seems a little bit
too passive for me into a blob of grease
he decides to go ahead and take with
this night here on a5 and then the Queen
comes down and exchanges on a5 so cloth
pushes pawn to g5 force the Knights move
Knight d7 95 we takes here on d2 so we
do see the Queen's come off the board
Bishop takes rook recaptures this is a
nice little square for this rook here on
d5 can't be chased away by the dark
square Bishop that black has and just
controlling the center of the board
right here pretty nice Knight to c5 pawn
to h4 wants to make sure that this pawns
protected here on a g5 does have as a
bishop it doesn't want that to be tied
down to defending for the rest of the
game casts on the King side pawn to c3
not sure I'm I'm a huge fan of c3 if we
look at what White's looking to do here
I think he's done a good job with his
pawns on the King side of the board he
can start to change his approach to the
Queen side of the board he could play
rook to c1 if you want to push forward
pawn to c4 he could just automatically
just push forward pawn to c4 he could
recapture with his Bishop if he needs to
really control the center could play
pawn up here c4 and then swing over over
with his rook to c1 could play rook d1
and just load up here on at the default
think he has a few options pawn c3 not
one of my first choices Knight here east
six starting to do attack a little bit
more on this pawn on g5 Bishop down d1
pawn f6 trying to break up those pawns
look down here d2 pawn takes pawn up
here b3 pinning down the knight
on e6 to the king here and then rook
down here see four is a pretty
interesting move from Nakamura saying
yeah I'm willing to give up this rook
right here because yeah I can have some
some pawn advantage over here on the
Kings side of the board and I think I
like my chances with more pawns than you
so we see the bishop take here on a g5
the knight recaptures probably a worse
if he takes with his bishop here then a
rook up here taking on d6 still pinning
down this rook here also threatening
this Knight
so does need to defend this Knight so
maybe king f7 pawn takes that bishop
here on to g5 the knight takes now the
bishop takes and this is gonna be in my
opinion easy in game for Topalov with a
you know good amount of pawns compared
to his opponent there even Annie has two
rooks compared to rook and a knight
that's just easy pickings for white so
in the game we see the knight take
instead and so after the pawn recaptures
now the rook can swing down here take on
f3 and it's a whole different ballgame
now we have four pawns in the center and
the King side the board compared to just
these two for Topalov pawn to a4 so
White's say hey I need to attack on the
Queen side the board the King sides not
going as I had planned
King to g7 Bishop takes that rook here
on a c4 so we see the exchange network
to d5 great square for the rook on d5 it
is gonna be holding down at this Bishop
on e7 or eventually the King could come
over here and protect this pawn but
definitely a good square just needs to
hold down the fort and make sure that
his opponent especially doesn't push get
rid of this pawn here on g5 and then
just push these pawns down on the Kings
headboard
he's not gonna be able to swing the rest
of his pieces over and protect that
threat rook here to f8 King a2 rook over
here b8 threatening this square here on
b2
rook g2 trying to defend this square
here on a g5 so so important at this
Falls it's gonna be very very difficult
for Topal off to hold on nakamura
continues king f7 now that the queens
are off the board
deciding wants to get his king involved
into the game
rook down here d2 still putting pressure
but recognizing that the king is going
to start coming in so wants to swing it
over and try to control this open file
on the F file rook to h8 decides hey if
I want to start pushing forward on the
King set I can do that
King bee one pawn h4 king C to pawn a
serene you can see Nakamura this is
gonna be difficult for white to deal
with it's gonna be difficult to really
push this the entire way because it is a
light square that this pawns going to if
you have a light square bishop this
would be much easier but he's not gonna
be able to defend this square with his
bishop so because of that toe bluff can
stop this it's just more of a nuisance
that he even has to worry about this he
would like to really be attacking his
opponent instead of worrying about this
past pawn rook to h2 trying to stop that
but what's nice since this pawns come
down to the third-ranked now the rook
can come down h4 attack this pawn then
he has a passed pawn on the e-file
really starting to put a lot of pressure
on his opponent so rook to g3 says yeah
I'm gonna give you that pawn I'll take
this past pawn over here on h3 so I
don't have to worry about it nakamura
says yeah that's fine with me I'm gonna
go ahead and tack in the center I think
that's gonna be more of a pain for you
to deal with rook takes on h3 pawn d5
rook up here eight-six attacking the
pawn king f5 defending that square so
not come we're doing a good job of using
his King to stop any sort of attack rook
here to h7 attacking the bishop bishop
takes on g5 you can start to see the
huge attack that Nakamura has with his
pawns after the Bishop takes rook to f7
forcing the king to move or the bishop
really only has two moves Bishop comes
back here or King to e6 I think this is
probably worse just dicks disconnects
his pieces and this could really just
stop the King from coming over here from
the seventh or from the F file so
decides to go ahead and just block that
with his Bishop here on f6 and then pawn
a5 noch amol responds with rook down e
to check King d1 rook here to f2 wants
to make sure that his opponent doesn't
do anything with rook to f3 forcing the
King to move and then potentially taking
this bishop we're just putting him in a
weird position so rook to f2 does stop
that Keeney 1 attacking the rook and
then rook up to f4 buys him a few moves
if the king wants to start coming up
here on at the e-file decides not to do
that rook to g2 and then d4 black starts
to gain some space here and starts to
push his pawns right here and then white
has a few options he really needs to be
looking at this and saying all right
I've got to deal with the center of the
board I have two rooks those are the
strongest pieces into the end game
compared to a rook and a bishop but I
can't let my opponent dominate with the
pawns in this end of the board that's
really black's main advantage that he
has so he needs to be playing something
like a pawn takes here on d4 pawn
recaptures that's fine rook to c7
attacking this pond right here this one
is going to fall and so from there I
think White's gonna have a pretty good
game unfortunately
topalov decides it's not as important to
defend the center and he plays rook to
a7 attacking this pawn the game's just
not about this pawn here on a 6 huh from
here we see pawn to d3 pushing that
advantage anytime you have a passed pawn
always good to push that the rook takes
on a6 sure
but then black actually lets white come
back any place pawn to e4 knock'em or I
think missed the move Bishop to h4
this kind of buys him some time he can
always play pawn to e4 if he wants to
but this gets the bishop out of the way
his opponent will have to move now and
then he can play pawn to e4
so as bishop is in the attack doesn't
have to worry about it ever being
attacked by this rook here on a six so
much better move kind of an in-between
move anytime you are in a chess game and
you find a good move see if you can
improve that position before you
actually do that move it especially if
you can put your opponent in check a lot
of times that will allow you to get into
that position so Nakamura plays pawn to
a e4 not the best move really from here
you can see the best move will be rook
takes on f6 and then if the King were
decide to take here then rook to f2 and
just says okay that rook is going to
fall even if the pawn comes here to d2
that's fine rook over here to d2 if we
see an exchange on board maybe the rook
takes and then the King takes here on f2
this King can stop these pawns pushing
here and then we're just gonna see this
pawn push over here on the a file so
this is gonna be good for white these
players don't have a ton of time that's
one of the things you see in the Blitz
tile games they really can't calculate
it is this gonna be a really good move
if I decide to take the bishop here I
have two rooks my opponent has a rook
and a bishop should I take this I'm not
sure decides not to calculate that
instead just play rook to c6 doesn't
really understand the threat that's on
boards who wants to start chipping away
at the pawns
unfortunately for tupelov that's
definitely not good because pawn to e3
it just gets away from them there's no
way to really stop the threat here rook
to c5 trying to check his opponent but
it does does doesn't matter it's too
little too late King to e6 rook up here
to c6 King d6 our d7 attacking the rook
the rooks gonna have to move and then
the pawns can push freely and eventually
end up winning
the game just no way for white to stop
this so all in all Nakamura great game
from him
Topol off struggling it at this points
down four games after that you know the
first game day two and three coming out
the gates prepared playing the e for
meeting the Sicilian offense the night
Dorf defense had a very specific way he
wanted to go about that with f3 early on
castle on the queenside
but both the variations he's tried just
not working too well for him exciting
game nonetheless and seeing a lot of
great chess and going on from all of our
matches all the competitors hopefully
you're enjoying the tournaments and I
will see you tomorrow for some more
coverage